what's going on you guys Lord add here
I'm here with Travis we are doing kind
of you know just a back and forth
conversation about the reviewing process
in the industry you know particularly
IGN because he does review for the uh
for the IGN platform and you know first
off I got a little bit of bulletin
points I didn't want to like write too
much because I wanted it I didn't want
the show filling scripted I don't want
any of these to feel scripted I want
these to fill just a genuine
conversation so first off Travis go
ahead and uh give the audience who
doesn't know you and I'm sure a lot of
them know you uh just a general idea of
what you do and you know what led to
this
conversation yeah uh my name is Travis
Northup people online call me Tai guy
because I wear a suit and um yeah I've
been writing reviews about video games
for over a decade probably close to 15
years now and um yeah it's that's what I
do I've been been writing for IGN for
maybe four or five years and uh love it
love critiquing games love playing games
and talking about them and so uh any
chance I get to talk to anybody about
reviewing games and why I think it's
super important and uh valuable to
Gamers uh I I take the opportunity to do
so so happy to be here yeah I appreciate
you coming on because you know uh I
think these conversations are are vital
especially when it comes to media and
influencers I don't think the two of us
have enough conversations to really you
know there there should be more
conversation in general not just like us
like just in general cuz I feel like
there's a lot of resentment and a lot of
angry like
bitterness uh any other adjectives I can
use between media because you know
sometimes the media people take shots at
us uh most of the time we take shots I I
call them influencers because that's
that's what that's what the industry
refers to us as as influencers so you
know first off I want your overall
perspective
cuz I know obviously you do the
reviewing process on the IGN but I'm
sure you you have the overall idea how
the whole reviewing process works I just
want your your idea of the reviewing
process and the gaming industry in
general right now not just IGN just from
Metacritic to how they're handled
towards if like code sent out you know
one of the things I want to really get
your opinion on is like games like
coming from the Bethesda uh Studios you
know pretty much Giant games in general
cyber Punk Witcher these are massive
games that take sometimes hundreds of
hours to do everything in the game you
know uh I know they sent us the code for
uh Starfield like two weeks before it
came out uh do you think that's enough
time to do something like that while you
go over your opinion on the industry in
general when it comes to
reviews okay so first I think you asked
uh just an overview of the review
process like ideally or how it works
just how it works cuz the reason I
brought up the the Bethesda thing cuz
because that is part of the process on
how long they give you to review these
games yeah that's a question I get a lot
and we talk about a lot internally so um
yeah the way um reviews work and why
they're important which I think is
another thing um I like to explain is
that uh you know
um media Outlets exist to help uh
consumers or Gamers right if if we're
using the
colloquialism um help them navigate the
market like understand what games are
out there that maybe they they should
get excited about or or what have you um
and I know some people say online well I
don't need IGN or anyone else to tell me
uh I'd like to play the game for myself
and that's great if you have unlimited
time and unlimited money to do so but
you don't always and so the idea is well
what if you had a friend whose job it
was to play all of the games and tell
you what they think of them um and I
think that's really what um media
Outlets are for they are your peers
we're just fellow Gamers we're not
people making games in the industry or
working for Publishers or anything like
that we're just fellow Gamers who
gathered together and decided to start
covering the industry and telling you
what we think about it and reporting
news and that sort of stuff and so I
think when media works it's a really
kind of a Grassroots effort by regular
Gamers to just write write about the
industry and tell you what they think
about it
um and that's certainly the approach I
take and that IGN takes IGN's review
style guide says that you know our our
North Star is that we're trying to um
recreate the friend on a couch
conversation in our reviews right you
ask your friend oh you're playing that
new game Starfield well what is that
like and then you know so we try to
avoid using crazy lingo or jargon or
anything like that we just want all of
our reviews to sound like a guy just you
know explaining to you on the couch
exactly what he thinks of this game and
so that's what we try to channel and and
just to interrupt you real quick I think
that's a lot of the content creation uh
creators way too A lot of the reviews I
see yeah it it definitely seems like
they're recreating that and you know
when it comes to something like that I
think that's the best approach but you
know what's funny is we'll get into a
second is like the Dunkey video where it
does seem like a lot of reviews when you
put them out uh especially with uh media
outlets and I would say a lot of content
creaters do it too it seems like
everyone goes with the same script and
that's why you know I try to make it a
little bit on like you know just yo this
is what I feel I try to get quick in and
out for the most part and I don't really
give like any kind of numbers on
anything because I feel like a lot of
people weaponize the numbers at the end
uh and it's just like I go to the point
where it's like is it worth your money
that's how I do that for sure yeah I
have a I have trouble with the money
conversation because money means
different things to different people
some people have unlimited amounts and
doesn't mean anything and so it's really
hard to say is it worth your money um or
time for that matter some people have
lots of time and some people don't um
and so I I try to keep that stuff out of
reviews and that's actually part of
IGN's style guide is to not talk about
money or how much a game costs because
some games are amazing like Apex Legends
which is free and some games cost a lot
of money like Nerf Legends which is a
full $50 $60 game uh and are really bad
and so I don't know if money helps the
conversation but anyway we're already
getting into the depths of this um so
the kind of the purpose of a review is
um the reason we review the game is
because we want to speak to our audience
and create something that's useful to
them which in this case is a
recommendation or not a recommendation
for a game and the reason Publishers
provide codes to outlets like IGN or
influencers uh YouTube folks twitch
streamers is because our interests are
sort of aligned in that we want to cover
your game because we think our readers
care about it and you want your game
covered because it's publicity right and
so you're willing to give a a copy of
your game because you think it's good or
you think if it's not good that it's
still worth the coverage you get by uh
providing a code to whoever you're
providing it to um we take those codes
early we play the game as much as we can
and then we write our thoughts about
what we think of it um at IGN that also
involves assigning a score which I think
is important because it is super useful
to readers who want to know how much
something is being recommended or how
much it isn't being recommended um and
they can kind of decide for themselves
if they agree with that review or if uh
you know to me the most important part
of the review is explaining the
reasoning behind how you came to the
conclusion you have because even if you
disagree with the score you can see oh
well this person rated a nine out of 10
but the things that they highlighted
that they didn't like they trouble me a
lot more more and therefore uh I I
probably would like that game less than
this person liked it and so I think that
stuff is is useful um that's how the
review industry works I think it's super
valuable to Consumers we get that all
the time you know if I give a game a bad
um review score the first thing I see in
the comments is people saying oh thank
God I you know had this on my list or I
pre-ordered this I'm going to cancel it
um and when sometimes we recommend games
that nobody has heard of and then they
go out and buy it like I did a couple
months ago and I recommended Dave the
diver to the world um and that's a game
that might not have been on a lot of
people's list but then they go out and
they play it and I think that's super
cool too um your other question about
how much time we get it sort of depends
obviously more time is always better I
will never say no to more time um but I
understand that these games are being
made um really down to the wire these
days a lot of them are not finished
until you know the day one patch or
sometimes even after the day one patch
um and so obviously I prefer more time
but I do think the amount of time that
we got for Starfield which I think was
it might have been a little bit more the
time than you got it I think we maybe
had three weeks it felt like I was
playing it for about three weeks before
that game came out um and uh I think it
was certainly enough time to draw a
conclusion on the game because I think
after 60 to 100 hours you sort of settle
on how you feel about Starfield uh
regardless of if you haven't seen every
side quest or whatever you kind of get
it right you don't have to play 300
hours or something to tell your friend
whether or not they should play it um
some of us did but I don't think it's
necessary so I hear you um I think I
think two weeks is is pretty substantial
a matter of time you know especially
I've had a lot less oh yeah I I I P3 is
here's here's a here's a something you
want to talk about uh a the way it
shouldn't work um tomorrow payday 3
comes out uh
it's entering
early which is not real uh it's not
really early access it's just they're
selling you the money the game and
making you pay more if you want to play
it on time um and they sent out uh
invites for people to for Outlets to get
copies of the game and the Embargo was
for the day that they release it into
regular access and you're not allowed to
publish reviews about it before that
date and so IGN politely said no we are
not agreeing to this embargo because the
game is out already by the time you want
us to publish a review and so you know
we're just buying the game ourselves and
we're just going to play it tomorrow
when it comes out uh into Early Access
quote and uh we're going to write our
review whenever we damn well please
because those embargos are manipulative
and I think not not true so that that's
where I wanted to go actually was one
the next question uh first thing I
wanted to tackle was like the industry
in general then go into you know IG in
particular
I do think that sometimes Publishers
PR they use the reviewing process to
really put the curve more on their end
yeah to put the curve more on a cudle
yeah absolutely if you if someone came
up to you and said
Travis how would you change it how how
do you think these things should be done
because I I think that there are certain
scenarios where the Embargo list to dat
comes out where it most of the time it
looks fishy and then there's certain
times where certain developers are like
just do it just to do it and it's just
like I feel like there there's room for
improvement in there where things could
definitely be better more transparent
because I I'm keing on transparency you
you you tell me everything up front and
I think it'll work out better for you in
the end yeah so it's certainly true that
Publishers try to make their games look
good and I mean that's their job right
they're an extension of the marketing
team sometimes they are the marketing
team and they're trying to get good PR
um but I think um I think there's no way
to prevent that you ask me what I could
change I mean obviously if I could
change it I would make it so that you
know the pr agencies genuinely want the
truth to the the actual truth to enter
the public forum and for them to
understand it but I don't think that's
ever going to happen okay so let me let
me ask you this then yeah if more people
did what IGN did and when they got
embargo that's like very you know fishy
they just refused it do you think that
would change things or do you think PR
would be like you probably weren't going
to roll in my favor anyway and just keep
it moving I think that they would do
that if more Outlets did it because they
know IGN's going to cover it anyway
they're just going to cover it after the
game's out and I think what they're
trying to do is they're trying to not
ward off the people who are going to buy
it on the first day and so they will
view the IGN any traffic that they would
get as like maybe convincing additional
people to buy it or if it's a negative
review which we don't know yet because
we haven't reviewed the game yet um to
uh you know it'll be a hit to them but
it will be after their loyal their most
loyal fans have already bought the game
in Early Access and so Early Access I
hate that term by the way I keep using
it because it's their term but it's not
real that's not that's not what it
actually is it's just it's just like you
get it a couple days after it went gold
like yeah it's basically like what they
should do is they should call the
standard version late access and then
they should call the the quote Early
Access version just the regular release
because that's what it is um but yeah I
I I think um PR Industries are always
going to PR companies are always going
to work in the interest of their clients
and if it's done internally they're
going to do it in the interest of their
game and they're going to want it to
appear to be a good game when it hits
Metacritic or when people review it and
I think that that's okay for them to do
it what what's important I think is to
have the other balance of power right
which is the people who are are
reviewing it are allowed to give their
honest opinions and are unafraid to do
so and um I think that those two levers
they help right it's like having a a a
prosecutor and a defense attorney right
it's like they you kind of need that
push and pull um to make things work and
so I don't expect PR companies to ever
change or Publishers to ever change how
they give out codes and they're always
going to try to turn it in their favor
if I could change one thing about the
process I would actually change consumer
Behavior to not buy the game before they
think that it has reached the public
forum an opinion has reached the public
forum and that they can make an informed
decision because I feel like a lot of
people allow themselves to get caught up
in the hype of marketing and they buy
the game before they've actually heard
any of their peers say what their
opinions are or they do this weird thing
where they don't trust their peers right
like they'll get an opinion from IGN and
Gamespot and a bunch of other places
that say like yeah this game is good or
yeah this game is bad and they'll go
well I don't agree I don't believe you I
think that you are doing it because
you're bias biased or you're doing it
because they paid you or some other
reason which just isn't true and I think
if anybody had any interaction with
these organizations they' know that
that's not our angle or how our
organizations make money at all um and
we are actually just trying I mean our
interests are aligned like if we create
good content good reviews more people
are going to read them and if we have
more readers then that's more money
because more visitors on our site like
our interests are aligned there's never
any reason we would act against the
reader interest because it's our own
interest and so I I have trouble with
that but I if I could change anything I
would just change that because I think
that's the only thing you really can
change is to get people to not buy into
Early Access definitely not especially
if they're not allowing reviews to
happen before Early Access takes place
and and maybe to wait a couple days to
buy the game instead of going ham on it
right away I think if no reviews have
been given I think the biggest thing
that I would change is like I feel like
there there's too much like too much
going on when it comes to like
influencers media like there's too many
layers like I I I don't know how I
cannot tell you how how long IOP fought
to like get more access and then then
when you get in the access you realize
there's tears of access not everyone's
alike and to me if you're going to give
a c and people say oh addict you know
you're being entitled if it's like no
it's like if I know I'm getting a code
and I've been told I'm going to get a
code why I got to wait three weeks why
don't they all go the same time to Media
to influencers to smaller websites so
everyone can question yeah answer that
for me yeah I can tell you why that why
that works that way so um the reason
codes has started to go out in tear
which is kind of a new thing because uh
it's only kind of recently that
streamers and influencers and YouTube
guys have uh started to get these codes
and be considered like kind of rough
equivalent of outlets like people look
at ACG or um skill up and go oh yeah
these are where I go to for my reviews
is uh it's the marketing team trying to
pad out when their news hits right
because if all the news about your game
happens on the same day then that's one
big we're trending moment and then it
dies down but if you spread it out
across different segments where you have
proper traditional media companies and
then you know a couple of your most
favorite influencers and then less
important tertiary influencers or
smaller Outlets then you get to spread
out your trending throughout three
different weeks where they hit on
different weeks and all that stuff and
so it literally is just them working
marketing the other thing that people
don't realize is that the vast vast vast
majority of the time the publisher has
to pay for the free copies they're
giving to outlets every single copy uh
and that's because there's rules on
these platforms so if it's like an Xbox
copy or a PlayStation copy the 30% that
normally needs to get get paid out to
thatat distributor they pay that 30% so
they don't obviously don't pay the 70%
they would go to themselves but they pay
that 30% and when you start to do the
math about how many codes they actually
give out which number in the thousands
it's actually a huge expense like I was
talking to a publisher who she'll go
unnamed but he was talking about an
upcoming game he released this year and
he said that they were already
estimating it was going to cost them
like hundred plus th000 just to get the
review copies out the door which is like
a lot of money and so it's not like they
have unlimited funds to do this the
exception to that is if the person
releasing the game owns the platform
right so Microsoft Starfield they could
give unlimited because they don't have
to pay either fee right and so they they
don't really have a reason to not give
them at least that's my understanding
there might be tax laws I know that some
some countries like I bet Europe you
have to pay some sort of tax if you give
a European Outlet which is why a lot of
that continent got skipped uh would be
would be my guess uh but I don't
actually know the the logistics in there
I just know that there is a cost
associated with it the vast majority of
the time and that can be burdensome and
it makes people think that they're up to
something fishy for me I don't really
care how a publisher does it as long as
they're earnestly trying to get the word
out to as many people as possible I have
a problem if they're trying to choose
Outlets that they think will side with
them or think that we're about to get
some biased opinion which I I have a
problem with and then the final thing is
embargo time I feel like you have to you
have to give the Embargo time before the
game is available in any form to the
public before you start Chang them they
changed the Embargo and like that's
another yeah Liza P just changed it
although they changed theirs a day
earlier which I would say is a good
thing but maybe they only did that
because they thought the reviews were
going to be positive right and they were
feeling feeling confident about it and
that that's another thing I've seen like
I saw with Dying Light too like
different embargos for different media
like okay getting codes that's one thing
but when you're giving embargos okay
this is an embargo for certain websites
um this is an embargo for certain
influencers I'm just like at that point
no wonder there's embargo breaking all
the time because there's so much
confusion on who goes when yeah so a lot
of those deals like if it's individual
basis it's like oh you're one of our
most valuable influencers so we're going
to like give you an exclusive like you
can do it 24 hours early and they'll do
something like that uh and I I tend to
agree with you that I think that it just
causes more confusion and I'm not a fan
of Publishers picking their reviewers
because you can pick who you give early
copies to that's fine I think it's a
little shady if you're trying to be
super selective to twist a positive
result for your company but I expect you
to do that but you know there should
never be a case where you know the
there's a a Chosen Few that are selected
to give the review and then everyone
else has to give the review two weeks
after the game's out when everybody's
already kind of made their purchasing
decisions because that sort of defeats
the purpose of a review and before early
copies were thing which there was a time
where early copies were really hard to
get you either had to go onsite at the
studio and play the game or you had to
get a physical copy ship to your house
and played early and all that stuff um
before that I I feel like people only
really bought games if they if there was
something they were super confident they
were going to like and then they had a
tendency to wait until a verdict was
reached in The Gaming Community before
they spent their dollars and I feel like
increasingly that happens less these
days like it seems like people either
buy the game right at the get-go or they
buy it later and you know that might
just be instant gratification digital
downloads you know all that stuff that
allows people to just grab it
immediately once they see an ad um but
you know I just we're doing our best I
think everybody's trying to do their
best whether you're an influencer or a
traditional Outlet everybody's just
trying to like get information to their
readers as soon as possible
and I think 99% of them are trying to do
that in a really honest way uh and and
not do anything scummy but there are
obviously cases where people write and
say things that they shouldn't write or
that they don't actually believe that's
unfortunate so I only got two more
questions before we get to more IGN
Centric questions all right what is your
opinion on if someone truly has to beat
a game to review a game do you think
that it's one of those things that they
could put AB certain amount of hours but
not finished do you think there needs to
be those those credits before they start
doing a review yeah for me a review
really should you should you know I
wouldn't write I wouldn't watch the
first VHS of Titanic and then write my
review of Titanic oh it was a happy uh
little romance story nothing bad
happened right before I watched the
second half um I do think that you do
need to finish games and IGN has a rule
of for its reviewers that you have to
finish the game to write your review and
I think it's a good rule that said I
think there's some games that are less
about the finishing and I think there's
also room for like imagine somebody
creating a YouTube channel that was just
called first five hours review right
where they just for people who are short
on time who don't have a lot of gaming
time like people with kids hey here's
the first five hours of the game and
whether I think you'll enjoy it because
that's probably all you're going to play
I could totally see somebody creating a
YouTube channel like that and it would
probably be popular because I bet you a
lot of people don't make it past the
fight first five hours uh of games and
so I could see something like that but I
think a traditional review if you want
to be creditable
uh I think you have to I think you have
to play the full game and that's
certainly our policy at IGN yeah for the
mass majority of games I would say you
definitely have to see the credits uh
the only time I would say that you don't
have to see the credits you can review
is if you dropped a game and you're
explaining why because I think that's
still a review look I didn't like this
game this is the review on why I didn't
like it yeah or if you couldn't finish
it because you reached a gamebreaking b
bug um you know that happens sometimes
or if it's an online multiplayer game
that doesn't really have an ending
I would just say put like 20 hours in as
much as you can into the multiplayer
modes or however long you feel you need
to play to feel like you've experienced
everything there is to experience um
like I'm reviewing payday 3 which I
imagine I'm going to start playing it
tomorrow morning have it too nice I
imagine it's not going to um it's not
going to have an ending right really
because games kind of don't and so it's
play every Heist a couple times and then
start to form your thoughts probably so
so one thing I I I do want to like brush
up a little bit on like when it comes to
exactly how Cod are distributed now we
know that there's a lot of speculation
going on with Starfield on they Cherry
Picked who they sent it to uh first off
U what would you consider cherry picking
cuz I I'm kind of curious on that cuz I
don't think they Cherry Picked I think
they sent it out but they did avoid
people for a fact that they knew was
either being like negative on this stuff
do you think that when it comes to stuff
like that cuz like I see people like AB
bontis getting it I don't consider that
cherry picking uh you know CU to me if
they if they were truly going to cherry
pick it would strictly be one way one
angle I feel like they gave a lot of
Middle Ground now at the end of the day
do you think a company should stand on
morals when it comes to you know people
making statements on Twitter that they
didn't receive codes because of it cuz I
think there's a lot of that going on too
like you've you've made some outlayer
statements on you know maybe political
stuff or gaming stuff and we're not
going to give you a code because of that
do you think you know do you think stuff
like that goes on obviously it does but
I want your opinion on that because I
obviously Dr disrespect didn't get one
there's been a variety of people I get
that you know yeah there's been a
variety of people that didn't get codes
uh I remember uh digital Foundry and EUR
Europe digital Foundry was a big one I
think a lot of European Outlets didn't
get codes and I'm not really 100% sure
on that if there was like a cost
Associated like the tax thing or if they
simply just thought for whatever reason
that they didn't want to prioritize it
for some reason I'm not really sure but
which is interesting say it is
interesting yeah I can tell you this I
know that Starfield was cherry-picked
because I know the company that gave out
codes for that and my fiance was a
former employee there and she used to
decide who gets codes that was her job
and so the way that uh that company
Works which I I won't name the company
but yeah I know the company I won't name
them yeah you know the company um they
have a uh a tier list for outlets and
for influencers and so they have like a
tier B tier C tier yada Y and then they
have a a a even larger list of untiered
outlets people that or people or
organizations that they don't really
know if they have like a lot of clout or
they presume that they don't have a lot
of clout and typically what they'll do
is they'll give uh codes in order and
then see how far they can get down their
tiered list until they run out yeah
depending on how many they have
sometimes they'll take another approach
where they'll uh pick they'll try to get
like an even split between all the tiers
that's pretty uncommon usually they're
just trying to get as much press as
possible right so do you think they go
for more do you think they go for more
mainstream or more for what favors them
is a better Metacritic score CU we I'm
going to talk about Metacritic here
later but uh to me it it was like they
were trying to push that narrative their
way they would go for okay you know we
want people that's going to favored us
entirely but there's a lot of
influencers in some media sites that
just didn't like the game and they got
review codes CU that's why like I'm kind
of pushing back a little bit on like
truly you know CU truly Cherry pickings
mean you're going to CH you gonna pick
all the good ones all the healthy
cherries you don't want no black spots
but I didn't really see that and I'm not
saying they didn't cherry pick to some
degree but I don't think it as much as
people act like on Twitter that they
only gave it to people that they knew
would like the game I don't think that's
true I think that they they put their
thumb on the scale as much as they could
without being egregious and so I think
in their defense they they didn't try to
like intentionally screw themselves over
right like they weren't handing out a
bunch of codes to uh Outlets that have
like PlayStation and the title of their
name right like they didn't they didn't
do that uh should they have probably not
I would say like I don't really value
those Outlets that are like very
PlayStation or very Xbox focused but you
can see very clearly in the outlets that
the ones that they did give they kind of
green lit everyone who was an Xbox
Outlet right and then all the ones that
maybe they were less sure of they
deprioritized or didn't give a code at
all but I don't think that they
blacklisted big Outlets because they
thought that they weren't they were
afraid of their review score like they
gave IGN a code they don't know what
IGN's going to review it they didn't
know they didn't even know
who was reviewing it on our team Etc and
that's kind of usual there's like a
little bit of black box but I think they
made smart guesses they were like all
right here's all the people we have to
give a code to you have to give a code
to ignan they're too big of an outlet if
we don't have a review there it's going
to like damage our our PR like how many
people hear about our game and and read
reviews um but here's all the ones that
are probably untiered my guess is a
whole bunch of
untiered providers got codes with
priority for specific reason
the reason was because they thought they
would be a positive review do you think
they have mad people researching these
these people I know they do was a
researcher and just seeing like what way
they would tear left or right I don't
think it's specific people there are
exceptions to that rule where they'll
actually have like uh they'll put
together like dossier on specific people
like my fiance she was publishing a game
and she put together a dossier on
palassi because she knew palassi was
going to be interested in the game and
so it was like here's all the stuff he's
created the news coverage here's the
things he cares about and like gave that
to her manager whatever and uh but
usually it's for outlets right they'll
they'll have like a description of
outlets here's how big their reach is
here's the type of topics they cover
here's what they've given previous games
from this publisher in this genre they
do research on that stuff and so I know
that exists and my guess is they were
like yes to everything on a tier maybe
yes to everything on B tier except for
Euro for some reason and then uh we're
going to go through c-tier D tier and
untiered and we're going to say yes to
all the ones that we think are going to
be positive and that's that I expect
them to do that to be clear I expect
them to do that because PR is always
going to act in their interest and
that's fine as long as the other side of
the equation exists as well which is
that people reviewing the game are
acting in the interest of average Gamers
and consumers and are not afraid to give
honest feedback and that sometimes
happens at small Outlets where they're
afraid to give honest feedback because
they're afraid if they give a negative
review to a Nintendo game Nintendo's
going to Blacklist them and never give
them a code again and so there's a
little bit of that's why I'm happy I'm
lucky to work at a large Outlet because
I used to work at a small Outlet there
was a little bit of pressure there but
here it's like they can't not give me a
code so I'm gonna and even if they
didn't give me a code I could just write
the review late and then millions of
people because your reach is big enough
where you don't because my reach is big
enough I don't have to play that game
but I do think that there is there
definitely a game played on Starfield
specifically on the pr side to try to
make it in their favor and you can see
it in the Metacritic and the weeks
following right like the Metacritic has
slid down uh over time and I think that
that was probably expected based on who
they gave the review codes to um I don't
know if that's the worst thing in the
world right like I like I said I expect
PR people to do it but it's definitely
not good right like it's not it's not
super honest for them to do it but they
they they did what they could to put put
the cards in their favor there's like a
lot of guidelines for for stuff like
this but I do think this is one of the
guidelines that was overlooked in terms
of like form of government and stuff do
you think there needs to be a third
party looking at stuff like this like
because it's just like CU it would you
would make an argument that some of this
is false advertising like we are
strategically putting places where I
need them and you know don't get a Twist
of the whole industry does this I know
for a fact I've been told mul indry by
the way every industry does this yeah uh
I know for a fact that Sony's done this
uh Xbox obviously everyone has done this
to some degree it just some people are
well extra about it and some people uh
you know they dabble they sprinkle a
little into some people are yeah some
people are a little bit more open and
they try to just genuinely really good I
I can honestly say I've never had an
issue where Ubisoft like any way shape
or form has try to like shut me out of
anything like for the most part they're
like okay like just just there's also es
and flows depending on who's in charge
or which PR Company they're using to
because to be clear Xbox and Microsoft
did nothing on the review code thing
that was 100% the the uh P the not the
publisher the pr company that they hired
to do it they did it on their behalf and
so they're saying hey we trust your
expertise do what you do best and that
company's going oh yeah we we're going
to do what we do best we're going to try
to you know get this thing as as close
to what you think it's going to review
at internally as possible um and I think
they did a good job doing that I don't
know if there should be a third party
and here's why if if you're trying to
yourself in the publisher shoes or the
PR Company shoes you're saying I know
this game is going to get review bombed
by PlayStation people and that's unfair
therefore I should do everything in my
power to stack the cards in my favor all
I'm doing is fighting against a process
that could destroy a game that I think
is good and actually deserves like a
fair shot right and that's not in that's
not a crazy argument you could
definitely see that like you see review
bombing online I'm sure there outlets
that wrote disingenuous review RWS
actually we already read one right the
gym quisition review was uh it it cited
specific uh qualities about Bethesda as
a studio that that person didn't like
that had nothing to do with the game
right like that's just not an accept
that's not a review that's you reviewing
the studio maybe but not reviewing the
game um I think Hogwarts Legacy had a
similar thing where people were
reviewing
situations they weren't reviewing they
weren't reviewing the game and so if
you're a publisher and you know your
game is going to be controversial or
there's going to be people out to get
you I totally understand why you would
try to St stack the chips in your favor
I get that I I still think ultimately
it's a little dishonest but does there
need to be like a regulatory
body I don't know I don't think we're
that bad yet I don't think think we I
don't think any I don't think it's
gotten to the point where it's false
advertising I tend to believe the vast
majority of people who wrote Starfield
reviews and gave high scores genuinely
believe the things that they wrote I
think the vast major majority of people
do and so if it's just people giving
their honest opinions you will never
hear any outcry from me you know uh I I
would just say it takes all types look
at your favorite YouTubers certainly
look at the small Indie Outlets that you
trust but also I would say look at the
large Outlets even if you don't like
them because you have to keep in mind
these are the outlets that got codes
whether the publisher wanted it or not
and so I would put that a little bit
into your algorithm of like how much do
I trust these reviews cuz people say oh
I only trust you know YouTubers I would
say do the opposite like YouTubers are
fine I'm not knocking them I'm just
saying if I had to pick one I would pick
the one that is big has a separate
editorial team from their sales team
right YouTubers don't have that they're
the advertisers and they're the
editorial right and so there's a
conflict of interest there certainly uh
and they're you know they're the type of
people that a publisher could say no to
they can't say no to game gam spot right
so that's that that's my two cents and I
I tend to trust traditional media but
I'm a little old school that way I work
I'm also biased traditional media
clearly you're biased towards uh
traditional and I'm biased towards you
know content creation influen it's just
it's what we're in like I'm an influenc
interviewing a traditional media Outlet
reviewer all right so let's let's let's
go over IGN what's I I I want the
process that you can give I I don't
obviously I don't know if there's any
restrictions you talk about so the
process from uh you know who decides who
gets what review I want the beginning to
end on who decides it one thing I'm
curious and you could put this at the
end is I saw CIA star's review I watched
your guys's review on that and I noticed
there was a lot of spoilers in that
particular review uh I'm kind of curious
how that goes like does a person editing
it not know what he's editing or is he
just don't obviously he cares because he
works for IGN it's just kind of weird
how those slip through the through the
crack so go ahead and uh you know give
your take on that stuff all right I'll
give the last one first which is
spoilers um so the way a review works is
after we've done the written version
somebody will turn that written version
into a script which is usually shorter
they will upload all of the footage that
they recorded that they want to use in
the review and then they will annotate
the script which means like SC
specifically highlight lines and match
them to video clips that you want there
and then you pass it off to a video
editor to to push it together and and
add your vo and all that stuff and so
it's sort of a handoff to the video
editor we do talk about spoilers where
we're like hey do we think that this is
a line we don't want to cross where we
don't want to show this or we don't want
to talk about it but it's always kind of
a back and forth right because let's
talk about like temples and Starfield
technically talking about temples and
Starfield is a spoiler but if you don't
talk about that it's a big part of the
game it's a part of the game that I find
super annoying and so if no reviews are
talking about that at all yeah they're
really like mon right and so I think if
you don't talk about that like are you
doing a disservice to the to the reader
and so we to us it's a balancing act
like we try to measure like how much is
it worth showing this how important is
this to get the message across for why
we felt this way about the game to the
reader versus how much are we taking
away if they do this and so we we try to
avoid spoilers at every opportunity we
are not perfect some stuff slips through
um and we show things that we probably
shouldn't I actually don't know the SE
of star situation or how much of that
spoilers but my general R show like
in-game people in that thing my my my my
rule is if it's happens in the first
like 10% of the game 15% of the game I
don't really think it's a yeah I don't
either I feel like think so cuz usually
I record the first like five hours
that's gameplay story content if I have
that first five hours in terms of all
that that's not a spoiler and and you
know I try to stay way for more story
thing story thing I might do the first
hour uh but man I ain't going to lie to
you Travis this
they were showing they were showing like
the last boss to see a stars like okay
but here's the thing if you don't know
it's the last boss is it a spoiler I
feel you on that but at the same because
because I did that once where I was
showing a combat sequence and it it was
a a Digimon game where it was it was
literally just one Digimon fighting
another Digimon and all the comments
were dude you showed the final boss
fight that's a spoiler and all the
comments under that were they only knew
that because they beat the game exactly
and all the comments under that were
dude why did you write the comment now I
know that's a spoiler like if you would
have said nothing it wouldn't have been
spoiled for me so I think there is a
little bit there's a little bit gray
area right there yeah there's a little
bit of gray I would just say like ignan
tries to do its best I assume everybody
tries to do its best have to show show
some stuff of the game it is hard and
and it's hard to make something look
visually appealing without being able to
use all the Legos like exactly if you
just show the first five hours it might
all be like the snow area of Diablo 4
and that's not just compelling to show
just the same snow area for an entire
review so yeah I feel you um it's a
balancing act man we try to do our best
all right the other question was about
the review process how it gets assign
yeah yeah so we have a spreadsheet and
people add uh their name to games uh if
they're interested in reviewing it and
so over time the those games will have
like four five six names next to it of
people who are open to reviewing it and
then uh one of our editors will go
through either Dan Dan Stapleton or Tom
Marks and they will see who's free who
actually has time to hit the deadline
and isn't working on other projects uh
and it obviously it has to be a match to
that person's interests which obviously
they're adding their names to it so they
wouldn't do that if they weren't
interested um and their expertise uh and
then uh yeah just based on who's free we
distribute codes and try to get as many
games covered as we can but it's pretty
much like you know how everything I
assume like every Outlet works I think
l.net literally has that same
who's got time who's they they do a TR
board though they do a TR board all
right so I think I don't know why we
don't we well we have air table but I
it's kind of not good for spreadsheets
but yeah all right so these are some of
the community questions all right I I
strategically put it this way so it
would make sense to the conversation I
hate when people like do something later
on when it could have been put in the
show at that time a lot of people want
to know Ryan mcaffrey he he did a lot of
the the the information when it come to
Starfield he does unlocked he did a lot
of the interviews when it comes to
Starfield people are curious why he
didn't do the Starfield review now I
don't know you can't speak for Ryan but
maybe you have more of an Insight than
we do I have guesses my first guess is
that like he probably just didn't have
time Starfield is an incredibly big game
and I don't think he was on any of the
Starfield stuff I think he was playing
it privately but he wasn't like working
on the wiki team or no I'm talking about
interviews and stuff like it wasn't like
intervie the the the reviewing process
it was before yeah yeah so Ryan is the
previews
lead so he does all preview stuff which
means games that aren't out yet and so
typically once the game's out he stops
covering it so that would explain why he
was doing Starfield before and not after
right like he's that's his that's his
entire job and so uh Ryan Caffrey is one
of my bosses at the company and I work
exclusively on preview content for for
him uh games that aren't out yet they're
not reviews they're just hey we played
this game early and here's some of our
early thoughts or impressions in its
unfinished State uh and uh yeah so
that's why he's doing it as to why he
didn't review it my guess is probably he
didn't have time also Dan Stapleton was
available and wanted to do it and this
is like a game seemingly made for him he
he loves Bethesda RPGs he loves science
fiction Etc space combat he reviews all
of our space combat Starship games so I
think he was probably a better anyway so
uh we I do someone did ask CU Dan he
he's one of the editors right what's his
official title chief chief editor is
normal for him to review a game that's
he reviews lots of games Okay um uh he
reviews games but I'll say Dan is a very
specific type of gamer so he tends to
review games that are in his wheelhouse
and then anything he doesn't feel like
playing like I force myself to play
games that I mean I I I consider myself
an expert on any game I review because I
don't review it if I don't feel like I
can be an expert on it uh but he has a
much more narrow because he's a manager
at the company and so he has other stuff
he's got to do uh but whenever there's
like a big one that comes along that
he's super interested in like midnight
Suns oh turn-based tactics game oo yeah
that's Dan Stapleton because he loves
XCOM that's like one of his favorite
games ever um so yeah he reviews lots of
games okay so he's good at it there was
um after the review cuz Dan gave it a
seven out of 10 there's a lot of
backlash and I noticed has IGN ever did
a spaces on Twitter or was that the
first spes they ever did because I've
never seen them pop up uh it's just it
I've never seen a company review a game
and then do a spaces on justifying that
review uh do you think that that's like
a standard thing that you see CU like to
me it kind of It kind of felt
like to me personally Dan should have
just stood on that like no more outline
no more comments it's like I gave it a
seven deal with that and just walk
away to the Sunset and I kind of feel
like being more outlay is on Twitter
doing the uh you know the the uh the the
spaces uh obviously that someone on here
said Travis was you directly contacted
by IGN to make a statement on Dan's
review I put that on here I knew that
that's false but it's just cuz it kind
of felt like it was a coordinated attack
and I'm sure you you you don't think
that clearly but I'm sure you can
understand why someone on the outside
would see that cuz it was like it was
like layers and then it happened yeah I
mean here's the thing honestly before
the game came out I thought Dan's review
was going to be one of the higher
ones I'll be honest so we were not we
were not anticipating a like damage
control that uh spaces thing is pretty
standard like uh our our social team
planned it before the review was even
out different movings yeah they're
different departments different teams
and they were basically like hey this is
a big game there's going to be a lot of
people who are interested in it let's do
spaces and they do that occasionally but
I think they only do it for big games I
think they did one for Diablo that would
make sense from like a perspective thing
yeah if if it's if it's a big game just
get engagment get people talking about
the game um and it wasn't it certainly
wasn't to justify the review let's not
forget seven out of 10 at IGN means good
Dan liked the game he gave it a positive
score he just had quibbles with it and I
think maybe more quibbles than some
people had uh um myself included by the
way I probably would have given it an
eight but I think I think eight after
after after 250 hours and the last 50
hours the game crashing constantly and
falling apart maybe a seven is Justified
but uh I don't know I I didn't have to
review it so I haven't had to reflect
too much on what my score would be um
but yeah I I I I
honestly a lot of the team at IGN and a
lot of the other people I was talking to
like ionas and stuff while we were
playing the game there were not a ton of
like optimism around it like some people
were like I think this game is going to
get sixes on Metacritic I think it's
going to have a 70 Metacritic like
people were talking like that what did
you play it on I played on the series X
and PC I I played a little bit on PC I
had more issues on PC than I had on the
series X that's what I heard I didn't so
actually I didn't have really any
problems until 50 hours into the game
and then after 110 120 hours it got
really bad like it got like way worse so
and that was before the game was out but
um we were all kind of like talking
about the stuff the shortcomings with
the games how it doesn't explain systems
well the encumbrance problem the the
hump you have to climb at the beginning
when you have no skills uh all of your
skill points are are empty and uh I
think it was a lot of pessimism that
first like couple days and then people
started discovering the fun and the
conversation became more positive and I
think Dan got over that hump and
eventually liked the game but at the
beginning I think he was like thinking
he was going to have to give the game a
five or six and I think some people the
team stayed there some people are like
yeah I think Dan score was too high so I
I I didn't think that I'm surprised I
was surprised that the Metacritic was as
high as it was in fact I bet somebody on
the team I was like I bet you it's going
to be less than 80 Metacritic just based
on all of the people I've talked to
because everyone I talked to at the time
was like I'm having trouble with this
game but I think that might have just
been early Impressions before people got
through I think it's a lack of
information they didn't really give you
a lot of tools to know how to play the
game it's like we Bethesda fans thrown
into this world and we had to relearned
how to be a Bethesda fan on top of learn
like I had to tell four people might be
that I had to tell four people at a dock
because they didn't really explain it
too well like that's true that actually
was the fact that you have to tap a on
ships they didn't really explain that to
figure out yeah um yeah I think there
was a little bit of that on on the team
where luckily we had like 30 or 40
people playing so we were all sharing
tips and figuring things out together
but uh I I to me I attribute it mostly
to the fact that the first 20 hours of
the game to me felt really bad like felt
like you're just everything was a pain
the encumbrance was so painful the lack
of cargo space on your ship was really
really painful now I'm I'm sitting
pretty I've got Max encumbrance and my
ship has 12,000 cargo space and all that
so I'm chilling yeah this isn't really a
Starfield uh uh thing so yeah we'll go
ahead and move on for that but anyway uh
yeah the I will say this I think
sometimes when people get on on Twitter
and they respond to reviews and I'm
including Dan and myself and everyone
else I think sometimes that gives people
the impression that they're entering a
defensive position about their review or
whatever um and I think that's a fair
criticism I I don't know that that's the
right thing to do sometimes I can't help
myself sometimes I see people online
saying that they don't believe me or the
things that I said that I believed in
and I'll try to explain it to them
because I think they're genuinely asking
and other times it's just people saying
I think you're biased or I think you're
paid chill or whatever and those people
aren't really worth engaging with but
sometimes it's hard not to sometimes you
just want to talk to somebody be like
hey dude not to Men We human you be in a
bad mood then bam you on Twitter arguing
all day also yeah I gave it a seven I
liked it like I I totally get where Dan
might have been coming from from that
but I don't think that that invalidates
the review right like why would it it's
just that person reiterating the things
that they believed and trying to explain
it to the people who were asking them so
I think some people look at that and go
oh it's damage control it's like what
are we what damage are we controlling we
gave the game a positive review and
that's fine I I I get that some people
thought it wasn't as positive as it
should be but that's not a controversy
that's just you disagreeing reviews are
opinions Dan's opinion is that he thinks
the game is good not great and I don't
think that's a crazy opinion to have I
could totally even as somebody who likes
the game more than him I can see
somebody playing the game and see coming
to that conclusion I think what made I
think what made it worse is that you
know how people are they draw their own
conclusions I got my own uh uh my own
opinions you got your own opinions but I
think it was just it was it was
everything together it was the the
spaces thing the the tweets thing uh you
know what were the tweets I I I saw him
flip out on Tim Dog which ironically Tim
Dog did kind of literally ask him to do
oh yeah yeah but at the same time it's
like man you work at IGN like calm down
a little bit and I get it it's just
people get emotional especially when
you're on like people don't realize when
you're like especially you got you got
all these people who know you especially
being the target of something like that
being happened it's easy to Lose Your
Rocker for a couple minutes and and and
I get it and I think you know people
start bringing up the Kratos outfits and
him saying that he didn't like the
Bethesda purchase so like I can see how
people obviously the thing is is that
you have to disconnect you know Dan
personally yeah so it's easier but even
but even if I was disconnecting I think
that you would have to look at very
specific tweets and ignore all the other
ones to come to that conclusion because
it you know Dan was Kratos for Halloween
because he has a beard and he's bald oh
I hear but at the same time war was the
biggest there was another tweet where he
said Xbox can't make any good games so
you starting to put two and two together
he's going his Kratos I haven't seen
that tweet I would like to see I have to
bring it up and it's just I think I
remember I saw I saw that he tweeted
that he was not a fan of Industry
consolidation which I found that very
weird that people were saying that
that's a that that was anti Xbox like
that's an industry issue in general yeah
I don't know if consolidation is good
for anyone I mean good for Microsoft or
whoever's doing the acquiring but I
don't know that it's good for consumers
and I can see why somebody would tweet
that I'm not going to justify everything
Dan has tweeted I'm sure he's tweeted
stuff that I disagree with all I'm
saying is I'm sure you've tweeted stuff
he disagrees with I'm sure yeah but all
I'm saying is that people can criticize
Publishers and console makers without
having a bias against them or even if
you prefer like I can tell you
personally I know Dan's preference he
doesn't care about Playstation or Xbox
he's a PC Gamer and he sort of just
doesn't care about consoles at all um
that's his I think it's more of the
perception you know I get it get
especially the the outcries on Twitter
and stuff like that and it's just like
you know and you know how trolls are
they they smell blood they grab on
they they they misconstrue it but I
think that the adults on Twitter and I
assume that there are a few of those you
seem like one yourself um is that uh
they you know it's one guy's opinion and
you move on and you when somebody tells
you that they feel a certain way unless
you have overwhelming evidence I think
you should believe them and I can tell
you personally I Know Dan I know he
believes the things that he wrote I know
that he was looking forward to Starfield
more than any other game this year and
it it he still liked it but it
less and less than he expected right I
think people need to realize that too
like Dan could have thought this was an
eight out of
10 but the anticipation of playing it
for years the wanting to play it for
years and then playing
like it's not what I expected like that
can naturally knock you down a level
just that by itself yeah even people who
really really like the game nine out of
10 realize it has issues oh it's it's
got a lot of issues and that's why I
feel like I feel like Fair like I eight
Fair Seven's fair I think the re's fair
they're all fair I think the reason that
I gravitated more is because I really
like the the space combat like I really
really liked it probably spent the most
of the game shooting stuff down and it
seemed like bees has spent more time in
that aspect of the game than anything
else interesting yeah I I think it it
has a lot of experiments that don't work
that I was personally looking forward to
but I me yeah so the procedural
regeneration I think was a huge Miss on
that game that's my big beef with it so
someone wants to know uh Forza
Motorsports is coming out you know yeah
is there really hardcore Racers at IGN
that uh the person reviewing I don't
know if you know or if you're allowed to
say are they a hardcore racer yeah it
they are okay I don't know why they
asked that there's the yes answer on
that one yeah we have hardcore racing
fans uh I've not gotten to do a racing
review but I'm also a hardcore racing
fan but I think we have one or two
people who are like like way more senior
than me who really like racing games and
they're always going to get to review
those so I haven't I haven't gotten to
do it but yeah we do so this is a little
bit with that last question is it okay
to review a game that you objectively
don't like like you don't like that
gameplay you can't stand it like for
instance like a firstperson shooter like
a real Call of Duty head reviewing a
like a like a real-time strategy like an
XCOM or maybe Age of Empire do you do do
you see that going on in the industry
not just IGN but the industry
um I see it happening in
influencers you know that's say we do
that more than you guys I would doesn't
Dunkey doesn't Dunkey review games with
turn-based combat and then comment about
how he hates I give you that I'll give
you that in terms of rev because I think
what it is is like that's where being
under a brand because like when we
review a game it's under us when you
guys review games under IG so it's
easier for you guys to to pick and
choose those fights like we got to
content there's only one of us there's
only one of us and there's a bunch of
you so I think that's why influencers
have to like really do that stuff more
more I I do see that coming from influ
to answer your question I don't think
it's my my standard with review yeah it
definitely isn't I was gonna say I don't
I was gonna say I don't think that it's
the worst thing in the world because my
my general rule is you should review a
game if you think it would be helpful to
a certain group of people that you're
giving a recommendation to and if that's
useful fine if you hate Souls light
games and you're reviewing Li of p and
it's from the perspective of I'm a guy
who hates soulslike games maybe that's
useful to people who don't like
soulslike games who are wondering maybe
I should give P Liza p a try anyway so I
can see that maybe been useful I can
tell you this much that is not how IGN
does things ever right like if you they
always try to generally pick someone
that would actually represent that
Community if we don't have anybody who
feels like they are an expert or likes
that that genre we will not review the
game like literally we'll just skip it
because we're like hey look we couldn't
find anybody who jived with this game so
we're just not going to do it um our our
goal is to be because we're the largest
gaming Outlet in the world our goal is
to be as useful to as many readers as
possible so we typically pick an editor
who is not only an expert at that genre
but who feels like that game was like
made with them in mind right and then
they can talk about it in an informed
way from a perspective of somebody who
likes those games that's always the goal
um it's certainly what happened with
Starfield I reviewed Liza P because I'm
a huge Souls like fan Etc that's how we
do it cuz I see again this is more
towards influencers because I I do it's
like I said like we have to come up with
more unique ways of doing content so for
instance when I reviewed fora Horizon 5
I don't know about racing games and
I reviewed it off those merits like it's
like a casual person coming in from the
streets don't like racing Gam games how
does this game because this is supposed
to be the king of casual race scene yeah
no I think that's super useful I think
there is an audience of for people who
are interested in fors of horizon who
know nothing about cars and generally
don't like car games I think that can be
useful to a certain person I'm just
saying if you're a large media Outlet
that's probably not your strategy
because you're trying to be useful to a
large an audience as possible and
probably most of the people reading
reviews on for of horizon or people who
want to know if it's good because they
like those types of games so U that's
that that would be my opinion on it but
I I don't think it's I don't think it's
inherently bad to review a game that you
normally wouldn't have any interest in
because maybe that's useful to someone I
just I wouldn't do it at IGN all right
so so I got another question it's going
to be a weird one so we see games
constantly getting rebranded like dead
space uh did they do new things yes uh
but a lot of criticism goes in not just
IGM but you know the whole thing is like
should these games one be considered for
like game of the year and I know this is
off the review thing a little bit and
two do you think that especially like
definitive editions should they even be
re rescored cuz like you see a lot of
games like years ago got a low score and
then like two or three years later
they'll come out like the definitive
Game of the Year Edition and it's just
drastically higher I think one I can
name is Ghost to shishima like the
original one was a lot lower but then
they re-released it uh you know I
personally don't have a problem with it
but for some reason our community wants
your opinion on if that should be done I
do for me personally I think remasters
and remakes should never be considered
for Game of the Year ever uh because for
me game of the year is this is the game
that most represents uh a step forward
for the games industry these games had a
a structure already they had an impact
like they had their chance years ago
like give it to someone else ideally
there is a like you know there is a
before GTA 5 and after GTA 5 that is a
pure Game of the Year game because it
was a Masterpiece level that pushed the
industry forward in a specific genre
Hades you know perfected the Rogue light
formula that's a game of the year like
it just you feel it right um and I I
don't I can't think of a single remake
or remaster that's ever made me feel
that way and so but that is an opinion
right I'm sure some people are going to
play dead space and go personally that's
the best game I played this year Dead
Space remake I don't I don't think that
that's a a crazy thing to think it's
just it doesn't it doesn't conform with
my uh View of what game of the year
should be but there's no there's no
rules it's all subjective um and then uh
definitive addition so our rule at IGN
is we re-review games if there is
interest in that thing because again our
entire deal is being helpful to readers
and so if there's a whole bunch of
people interested in the definitive
addition of a game we will re-review it
because they care if they care we'll
re-review it great example of this we've
re-reviewed no man Sky three times
and the reason for that is because not
because it got definitive additions but
because a year later and a year later
and a year later it it met our two
requirements for re-reviewing a game one
significant enough changes that it could
theoretically change the score it's
changed the whole game and people still
care about it and that second one is
actually the harder one because
typically when your game comes out a
year later they're not talking about it
so there's no point in re-reviewing you
because it's even if your game has
changed a lot it's not helpful to anyone
because nobody is asking for a review of
your game they either have already made
up their decision or they're close to
the community and they're keeping an eye
on your forms and your updates and
they're already informed right and so
our goal is to be useful to readers uh
and I don't know if it's useful to
readers to re-review a game that nobody
is interested in um so yeah we do
re-review games and I think there is a
place to re-review definitive editions
but it's on a case-by Case basis I say
it's my last question I can talk about
Metacritic for a couple minutes okay oh
actually before that what do you think
about the Dunkey video I had that
parenthesis just depend time I actually
I actually didn't mind the Dunkey video
he had you in it a couple times he had
it in it a couple actually that's the
second video he's had me in uh so he had
me in a video like a year ago um that
was sort of similar it was like a so
when somebody sent me that video I
thought it was going to be him just like
laying into IGN reviewers and it kind of
wasn't that it was it to me the takeaway
was it was funny but the takeaway to me
was that like he was making fun of
commenters how it was more about the
commenters yeah the commenters tend to
think a review that video was a little
click bakey like a little click bakey
click click I mean that's his whole
thing right like he's kind of Shameless
and and out there and hyperbolic and
that's kind of why people like him I
don't have a problem with Dunkey I mean
I don't really oh you did okay nice and
he never comes outside so I don't really
watch uh any YouTubers so it's not how I
receive news or am interested in I don't
watch YouTube videos but but uh I
thought that video was funny I watched
it and it kind of made me laugh and I
was like yeah writing reviews at IGN
kind of sucks because no matter what
somebody's either going to say oh you
reviewed this game way too highly IGN
doesn't know what they're doing or oh
you only reviewed this game low because
you didn't get it or you weren't
qualified or you don't understand the
genre and I'm just like or I just didn't
like it and I disagree with you you know
what I mean like so I thought it was a
funny video though all right so let's
talk about Metacritic cool um let's do
it I feel
like meta critic is the engine and
websites is is like the gas like cuz it
it was like this Metacritic score be
getting ridiculous sometimes like people
people might weaponize all IG and gave
it a seven out of 10 but they're
weaponizing Metacritic to a completely
different point like and I get it I do
feel like Metacritic was originated for
a different purpose and then it just
completely got on our mind of its own um
you know it it's crazy U you know what's
your opinion on Metacritic first off and
second off is there any flaws that you
feel Metacritic should address because I
personally don't like the five out of
five not converting well I think
Metacritic should be very open with look
if you're not on a 10 out of 10 scale
because that's what harsh scale is
you're going to have to convert or you
can't be 100 point scale so they have a
but it's easier to convert to a 10 out
of 10 scale than it is a five out of
five so you know give your opinion on
that yeah yeah uh I actually think
Metacritic is useful to readers because
if you let's say that you've got a
couple reviewers that you trust or
Outlets you trust you can go ahead and
look at those individual opinions but I
do think it's useful to have an
aggregate of all of the professional
critic opinions out there and what the
looks like I'm watching you like Veno
somebody for pizza or something just
keep talking I'm listening yeah um I do
think it's useful to uh to have somebody
uh to have that aggregate score if
you're just looking up hey what are the
what's the general consensus about
Starfield oh it's high 80s awesome
sounds like people like it I think that
that's uh super useful to readers but I
think I have a problem with it being the
end all be all you can't just look at a
Metacritic rating and think that you
understand everything about the opinions
there because you might disagree with
the people that are giving it high
opinions you might disagree with people
that are giving it low scores I think
the best thing to do is pop in and read
a few or or even better go to a few
Outlets or creators that you trust or
specific people within those Outlets
that you trust like if you like my
reviews read mine and if you don't like
my reviews then when you see me
reviewing a game you go oh I just always
disagree with that guy so I'm just not
going to read that review or I'm I'm I'm
at least going to know that it doesn't
affect me anyway so I think they're I
think they're useful I just don't think
that they're
the they're not something to base your
opinion on really they they're they're
part of it they they certainly can help
inform part of your opinion like oh 40
on Metacritic that means a lot of people
didn't like it or at least everybody who
reviewed it probably didn't like it
except with a few outliers um I do have
problems with their system they have a
really weird like you can only give a
score on one platform rule which IGN
somehow gets around but other outlets
don't which I think is weird they have a
weird like uh waiting system where
certain Outlets are worth more weight
than others I don't know if you know
about that but like IGN's IGN's scores
on on Metacritic are like worth more
than other outlets are you serious yeah
in terms of the waiting if you do the
math on like it's not a straight average
of like all the scores across Outlets
it's like a weighted method so I don't
really know how it works that's just
what I've heard is that what just the
the standard IGN or like all the the
branches that you guys have like as I
know there's like an IG in Japan
yeah I couldn't tell you how it works uh
from International perspective but I
know that all I all I've confirmed with
a buddy of mine is that it's not just a
straight average and he was like yeah
look at this he like pulled up his phone
he was like look let's do the math and
he added up all the scores and he
averaged it and I was like oh my God
you're right that isn't just a straight
average um so I've seen it work in real
life but I just don't know I don't know
the specifics of it but there's some
sort of like blackbox algorithm that
they have to do Metacritic I will say
this I really don't like the way that
they consider mixed and negative reviews
because I think they have is it seven
out of 10 as a yellow that to me is a
problem I think it's like I said like
they're the engine you guys are the gas
because yeah that's why people see
sevens and stuff as bad now because now
every time you see a seven that that
that suck a yellow and people
automatically think okay that's mid we
don't want to play that like yeah yeah
well I I think um Metacritic might be
responding to a larger problem in the
industry which is that consumers
increasingly think that 8 through 10
equals good and 7 through one equals
terrible unplayable I think that there's
more room for nuance in a conversation
there are some seven out of 10 that are
really worth playing because you know
they've got a couple good ideas and if
you like that type of genre and you can
Overlook some of the faults and deal
with some of those caveats you can find
a good game in it but it it doesn't mean
that it doesn't just because you gave it
a seven or a six doesn't mean it has
absolutely no merit there's a reason you
gave it a seven and not a five or a four
right and so I just wish people
would have a little bit more moderate
opinions because there's just a tendency
online to say oh this is either the best
thing ever or it's literal dog
defitely was time and I hate that I just
I want people that's kind of part of the
reason I got into this industry to be
honest because I hate hyperbole I really
do and I just want I want to bring like
moderation to the games industry I want
people to say you want to be that third
that third party units yeah it's just
like I right I want it's more like I
want like um something I really enjoy is
every once in a while I have to give a
game a really low score and that sucks I
don't like giving bad game reviews but
what I do like is I like using those
games as examples when people say oh
yeah Starfield is a two out of 10 and I
go no it's not here's a two out of 10
look at this game compare it next to
Starfield and tell me that you think
that these are the same you know because
I have a real problem with that because
yeah it's like um example uh Maddie uh
cogs cogs friend the podcaster he said
death Loop was the worst game of the
year the death Loop was a good game I
like death Loop right even if you don't
like death loop it's not the worst game
if you think it's the worst game that
year you did not play many games that
year because there were way worse games
that year I think that was the year Nerf
Legends came out literally right so like
I I just I cannot uh you know I I think
that there's just a lot of hyperbole of
saying if it's not my favorite thing
ever it's the worst thing ever and I
really have a problem with that and I
think that's another difference between
you know standard media outlet and and
influencers we kind of get to choose
what we want to review like there's no
sometimes we'll review a game off of
like a like a friend or review something
someone told us but for the most part
we're asking for our review like and we
accept the ones that we want that's not
really given to you guys you guys
actually fight for your you know
senority to be able to review the stuff
that you guys want to review so when
Maddie saying that's the worst game I
played that year it probably was the
worst game in his opinion he played that
year I think he said it was the worst
game of the year not the worst game I
played oh no that's that's not that's
not it like I to me that that level of
hyperbole has no real place in the
discussion I just it bothers me and I
get I get the instinct to say it because
you're online and you're trying to make
entertaining content and you want to
just like say something that's a little
out there but I just don't think it's
super constructive and I have a problem
with with that so I don't know man
that's my whole thing I I get that IGN
is boring I get that like they're the
adults in the room I work for them
because they're boring I want to work
for the boring Outlet because I think
that boring is
responsible if your if your takes are
not setting the internet on fire I think
that you're doing things
right yeah so that's pretty much like
all I I when it comes to
Metacritic I think that the process
should be taken more seriously than it
is I think and this isn't towards the
bigger sites they have more immune to
stuff like they could do whatever they
want for the most part because they are
unaffected but um you know I do see a
lot of people
manipulating the system for personal
greed scores no just manipulating their
scores in general like they're going to
get traffic or you know they want to be
that outliner so they either go really
high or most of the time it's really low
we're talking about you know uh the
individual that gave it a four so it's
just like I see stuff like that I don't
think they did that for traffic I think
that I think she wrote that review for
but it's still they knew doing that
would do something actually you know
it's a better example of that there was
an outlet that gave Hogwarts
Legacy a one or two out of 10 and they
were from an outlet that does not score
their
games you know what's crazy too they
added a score just just for process just
for so that they could I don't know if
it was just for Metacritic but it was
just to say like put a stamp on it and
be like yeah this game sucks um just to
drag it through the mud dude uh and they
didn't even they're not they didn't even
score their games as an outlet normally
that that blew my mind I was like that's
like a new level and there was someone
that reviewed Starfield and gave it like
a five out of 10 or something and they
even said in the review they played it
for five
hours and it it's do you look I mean
reviews are based on trust if you trust
the person or the outlet that they're
representing uh then you know maybe five
hours makes sense to you because you you
know also within five hours whether you
like a game or hate it do I I don't
think you're doing yourself any favors
if you if you do that that that's my
last question we're going to close out
of it you know Metacritic clearly they
got some holes in the ship that they
just keep they just keep getting the
bucket of the water and just see at
these in it they never fix it uh I
personally don't blame the individuals
that manipulate metac crit for their
personal goal they're that's human
nature depending on morals almost anyone
would do that uh I blame Metacritic for
not patching their ship and letting it
continue that way right so yeah I mean
if I if I had if I were Metacritic I
would say hey we have standards now but
I mean standards now met Metacritic
Metacritic has sort of
a they're in a weird position because on
one hand they want to be a neutral
Arbiter right they don't want to say
specific like hey you can't be too
negative or you can't be too positive or
whatever they shouldn't be involved in
that and I'm glad they're not but if I
were Metacritic I would say hey we're no
longer going to include scores for
reviews that talk that address things
that are not part of that product right
if you say hey I'm giving this a two out
of 10 because um this company doesn't
recycle and I think that they're
destroying the environment and so I
think that I'm going to give their game
a bad score regardless of the content of
the game that's the sort of thing that I
think is like actually destructive to
the review process and so if I were
Metacritic I would probably enact a
policy to say we're not going to accept
those scores anymore if you my my
developer game buddy said that he read a
review of a game that he published that
he
developed and uh somebody said uh it's
too hot in my apartment seven out of 10
you know what I mean like oh my God you
know what I mean like and that was on
Metacritic and so I think if you're
writing a review it's too hot my
apartment 7 out of 10 I feel like
probably probably shouldn't include that
in the Metacritic rating that's how I
feel about it yeah that that's my
overall thing when it comes to reviews
you know I want to do the closing
statement it's like you know I always
take passion over everything and you
know you're actually the only Outlet
reviewer I I like I read I don't see I
don't read that's why I'm an influencer
I don't write I don't do none of that
that but when I when I Know Travis when
I Know Travis is revie it okay okay I
I'll I'll get the glasses and I'll read
I appreciate that man and what what I
like about you is like I feel like
people either are too hard on games or
too soft on games uh but I feel like
you're one of the few that I feels in
the middle you know you you you you hit
you you go for the doubles when you feel
when you feel it's Justified but I don't
feel like you attack something just
because it's that and I and respect that
and you I had a lot of that's my goal
man that's my goal I just want to be a
moderate guy I had a lot of
people and members was like Travis is
the dude to have this conversation with
uh so you know you got got got a lot of
love with the community but you know
Trav closing statement man you know what
where can the people find you at yeah um
they can find me all my stuff on ign.com
and they can follow me on Twitter Tai
Travis if they want um I also do some
YouTube shows I'm on uh itis' show the
last word destiny podcast on Thursdays
and then I do a season gaming show bit
cast Sundays at 8 a.m. Pacific um and
yeah I just I guess my final thoughts
are just everybody remember reviews
their opinions people can have opinions
I think some of times very rare cases
those opinions are disingenuous and you
can kind of tell who those are right
like they're out there to make statement
that has nothing to do with the game but
I think by and large and I can say very
confidently all the reviews at IGN are
genuinely held opinions and if you don't
agree with them if something seems off
to you read the review and it'll have
the explanation there because I think
even a review you don't agree with you
can see how somebody got there if you
read the context and you can say oh well
a b and c thing that they complained
about isn't going to hurt isn't going to
I'm not going to feel that way because
that those that stuff doesn't bother me
fine then you disagree with theie View
and I think it's okay there's a lot of
room in this
subjective space of criticizing art
critically evaluating art uh for
disagreement and I think reasonable
Minds can differ and there's nothing
wrong with that so uh try not to get too
upset about the vast majority of reviews
you read out there because they're just
people's opinions yeah I agree and it's
like it's like I said I made one post
about the Dan thing uh I just quote what
your post all I said is I don't agree
but as a man's opinion it is what it is
um I did post about the whole Tim Dog
thing that was a different thing but
that wasn't had nothing to do with the
revie I don't I don't know what that is
but yeah uh yeah I think that's a
totally fine opinion you can even say yo
I think your take is bad I mean I think
Paul tassi said said a Seven's wild like
yeah he said a Seven's wild he very much
disagrees he really likes that game but
uh I disagree with tassie's opinion too
I read his review and I was like yo this
is way too positive like did you play
play the same game as me like this
game's got issues dude uh but feel you
know teach their own I don't look at
Paul's review and go oh well I I think
he doesn't believe that I think he's
only writing this review because he's an
Xbox Fanboy like you know what I mean
like I I look I read Paul's review and I
said well look I think he's overlooking
some stuff I would have criticized but I
believe he believes this and that's all
I need I know you know I know where Paul
tassy sits on certain games and I think
a lot of times I probably am going to
disagree with where he ends up with his
scores he also disagrees with the scale
he tends to think that if it's not an
eight it's bad and he he works that into
his review scale which is not the way I
operate uh and so I we actually had a
really long back and forth after the
Starfield review about why I think a
seven of 10 should mean good and he
disagreed and we kind of got into it but
it was a it was a good discussion paas's
a friend and uh I I trust that anytime
he writes something it's a genuinely
held belief and I respect that even if I
disagree with it and that's what I want
more people to do I I consider a seven
fun an eight good a nine great and a 10
like amazing like I always felt like
enss it people expect Perfection from
enss I expect the developer did
everything that they wanted with that
game to the fullest not necessarily it's
perfect yeah so 10ed IGN is Masterpiece
which means like we think this game is
going to be an example for other
developers in that genre going forward
it's going to be like
a landmark game nine is amazing eight is
great seven is good six is okay five is
mediocre four is bad three is awful two
is painful and one is unbearable and
with that we go in man Travis through
that scale from the heart boom got it
all yeah but I appreciate you coming on
Travis going to go and end this uh
definitely if you guys enjoyed this uh
you always subscribe to the patreon and
members uh I don't know if I'll post
this I'll probably post it eventually to
the public uh we got some weird stuff
going on with the YouTube channel but I
appreciate for coming through this is uh
this is Lord addict and Travis Tai guy
and we're out of
here